quand j'ai monté l'association des
artistes contre le sida je n'ai été
entendus que par une seule personne
immédiatement par monsieur chirac 1985
le sida fait des ravages line renaud
décide de créer l'association des
artistes contre le sida chez les
politiques
son ami jacques chirac est le seul à
répondre à son appel ensemble ils
organisent des gars la collecte des
fonds en 1987
jacques chirac premier ministre et maire
de paris reçoit madonna à l'hôtel de
ville pour un don exceptionnel de nous
que je voudrais remercier madonna parce
que c'est vraiment sympa de faire un
geste pareil c'est très symbolique de
son attachement à la lutte contre les
fléaux qui touchent tout le monde et
notamment la jeunesse
jacques chirac sera le premier chef de
gouvernement à insuffler une politique
volontariste contre l'épidémie et
notamment par la prévention en 1987
sa ministre de la santé michèle barzach
annuler une ancienne loi qui interdisait
la publicité pour les préservatifs
j'ai l'intention d'abroger cette loi de
telle façon que l'on puisse vraiment
faire d'informations à ce sujet qu'on
puisse bien expliquer que c'est le seul
moyen de protection dont nous disposons
concret non nous disposons aujourd'hui
milieu des années 90 en france avec
l'introduction des trithérapies le
nombre de décès dus au sida commence à
baisser en afrique
au contraire la mortalité explose
jacques chirac alors président s'en
émeut à abidjan en 1997
le président français a appelé à une
mobilisation mondiale pour étendre à
l'afrique du sida mais étendre à
l'afrique les médicaments de dernière
génération coûte cher pour récolter de
l'argent
un fonds mondial des nations unies est
créée en 2002 la france en est l'un des
principaux donateurs
en 2006 jacques chirac lance un nouveau
dispositif avec un objectif faire chuter
le prix des médicaments
je propose d'affecter le produit de la
contribution de solidarité sur les
billets d'avion à une facilité
internationale d'achats de médicaments
contre les pandémies du sida de la
tuberculose et du paludisme une taxe sur
les billets d'avion pour financer des
achats massifs de médicaments faisant
ainsi baisser les prix auprès des
laboratoires
cette taxe chirac s'est révélé l'un des
dispositifs les plus efficaces pour
récolter de nouveaux fonds et combattre
le sida en afrique en 2007 l'om s
annoncés ainsi une chute de 40% du prix
des médicaments destinés aux enfants
africains malades
[Musique]